and earlier today former president Trump
he called on the special counsel in his
cases to immediately drop all charges
against him especially in the classified
documents case uh following news that
Biden will not be charged and president
Trump called Biden's case quote a 100
times more severe and called out the two
standards of Justice in our country here
now with reaction is Trump legal spokes
person Alina habba legally speaking the
question I was just asking Greg Jarrett
and by the way thank you for joining us
Al
the question I was asking him now that
this is their standard that you can
willfully retain and handle classified
documents and not be punished for it
does that open up a legal window for you
and your legal team to go in and say you
know we need equal application of our
laws
here absolutely I think the one thing
that we learned today from special
councel her is that there is in fact and
not that we didn't know it Sean two
systems of Justice one if you're a
republican one if you're a Democrat
we've seen it time and time again you've
spoken of it the way that this can be
used and and what has become obvious
that they haven't really thought about
is they try and look impartial they try
and say okay we're going to raid maril
Lago oh maybe that was a little too much
let's peel it back let's look at Biden's
documents one thing they're forgetting
that is so clear to me as an attorney um
is that number one president Trump has
one thing that Biden as Senator Biden as
Vice President Biden didn't have the
presidential records act something that
has shielded President Clinton so when
you're looking at this dual system of
justice they're going to have to face
the music when we're in court they're
going to have to answer questions and
you know what we shouldn't even be going
to court honestly I agree with my client
100% they need to drop charges and let
Americans believe that we're not going
to be treated differently depending on
our politics I don't think they're
capable of it I think they have severe
Trump derangement syndrome but you know
it's very obvious what's happening here
but I do want to thank special counsel
her for making it very clear to the
American public that this man can't even
remember when his son was passed and
more importantly Sean did you see what
he said today in the press conference he
doubled down on it and said I didn't
think I needed to answer that question
well that's another problem that we
haven't spoken about you're sitting in
an investigation you have an obligation
to answer truthfully and honestly uh
today was just mindboggling they
absolutely should drop the charges we
shouldn't even have to go as far as to
defend it and then he went for then
right there he had a memory lapse I I
wear this every day my son's Rosary from
our lady
of no answer he didn't finish it then he
said you know General Ali of Egypt was
from Mexico on top of what else has
happened this week he couldn't remember
the name Hamas Francois meeran uh helmet
Cole of of Germany when it was Angela
Markle uh I I just don't know how many
of these moments he can keep having when
people stay in denial and by but and for
the record alinaa I I faced a lot of
criticism when I was probably one of the
first people out there to point this out
on a regular basis and you know how did
I get paid back in return they tried to
compare me to Joe well even Sean Hannity
once got that mixed up the names of Matt
Gates and Jason chaitz no I don't have
this problem and that's the problem also
he's the president of the United States
I don't have the nuclear uh football
next to me uh at all times of my day at
night I don't have that so you know I
don't know what the country going to
take
frankly probably would be see it for
what it is yeah we would listen they hit
you they hit me they hit anybody that
stands with what's right and the
Constitution stands with the moral
compass and the boundaries that we used
to have as an America we don't have them
anymore they fear what they are this
they know that President Trump is the
right person they know that we have a
candidate that's fighting him that can't
even spell Bob backwards and we're
sitting here trying to to deal with and
reconcile how we're safe as a country
well we're not which is why they're
making fun of us all around the world
which is why we're seeing what's
happening with our borders and it's
complete election interference it's
completely because they have to lie
cheat and steal in order to win in
November if we don't stop as a country
if we don't wake up and say this is a
man who just frankly can't do it and by
the way if he can't do it who are we
stuck with Camala oh boy we are in
trouble so as a country like Allan said
and I I love Alan dershwitz because he
is a Democrat but he sees it for what it
is we are in trouble we got to get
behind Trump right now if we want our
country back and that's the truth well
certainly this election is going to take
on a whole new significance I think
starting uh tomorrow and we'll see what
happens uh I think we all know that if
Donald Trump had these moments the media
coverage would be far different um and
and that's just the double standard that
we have uh Alina habba great to have you
thank you so much hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else